ONE OF MILITARY RACES ARE BEING
USED TO CONDUCT THIS, AN
OPERATION THAT MOST AMERICANS
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT, THAT THEY
DID NOT CONSENT TO, THAT
CONGRESS NEVER VOTED ON, AND
WHICH IS CLEARLY ILLEGAL.
AND WHERE THESE PEOPLE GOING?
THEY ARE BEING MOVED TO ANOTHER
FORM OF CUSTODY AND THEN THEIR
FATE WILL BE DETERMINED, BUT
WHERE DID THEY END UP?
INTO WHAT COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
PLACED?
HOW MANY FEDERAL DOLLARS WERE
SPENT DOING THIS?
DID THE PEOPLE WHOSE
NEIGHBORHOOD INTO THEY WERE
PLACED HAVE ANY SAY IN IT AT
ALL?
ON WHAT'S THE TOTAL NUMBER?
FEWER THAN 800 THEY SAY FROM
LAUGHLIN AIR FORCE BASE BETWEEN
THE STATES BUT WHAT'S THE TOTAL
NUMBER NATIONALLY?
WHY DON'T WE KNOW THIS?
WHOSE COUNTRY IS THIS?
WHO IS IN CHARGE?
YOU CAN'T JUST CHANGE THE
OPPOSITION OF THE COUNTRY
BREAKING FEDERAL LAW AS YOU DO
IT WITHOUT ASKING THE PEOPLE'S
PERMISSION IF YOU CARE ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, WHICH THEY CLEARLY
DON'T.
MAYBE WE CAN GET SOME ANSWERS,
LIKE IMMEDIATELY.
MAYBE REP